Oh hello, you are doing firepower
. I am a 19-year-old high school senior in high school in Daegu, Korea. I am running a channel on YouTube under the name of Dal Si.
I don't know, but let's take a picture first
[Music] Ugh Uhh [Music] Uh uh
4 w There must be a 4 w
Yes
, yes, yes, awning in the shop
[Music]
We ride horses and go to school, so religious students live in the dormitory
6 o'clock 20  When the minute comes, it broadcasts a wake-up call 1 Then get up and get on in
10 minutes, put something like that, makeup, etc., put it in 16:30 episode 1, use
the information on the
playground below.
Kotele still has a g30 waist, so it's a handful to finish once, not once, but country at all
[music]
wee center q5
or
ab cartel spans a
cooler I think the bell is rare.
Hack
[Music]
Look, we have an
only eat-in class per 1 period. After
class, there are 10 minutes of rest, and there are 4 periods.
5 we are
2 tones Login theme
der
[Music]
Pretty
ah ah ah we a we two step 1 we uh uh uh I uh
People go to the public health room and go to the health room and sleep for about an
hour  In 3rd grade, the module
class always gives me problems because the dance matches me so it's really
boring to watch
woo woo
I'll try it a lot
uh [music] we could dot pwr ah 222
we
te leer la dou I did
n't know I didn't
already have lunch at 12:00  does not exist
4 Cut this at 10 o’clock.
This is a blood that is not available overseas. I don’t like rice that I am trying to introduce, so it is rice earning and
that is samgyetang.
Do what you do Ah ah ah ah ah ah
benz If there is a time to spread the bullets This is a person’s consecutive terms
Lee In-ki hyung
Isuzu Urir Song city sells bread and is
large ant king
co
oh oh oh oh
wm drawing all 44
ham No
Yes Yes Yes Yes Now what kind of
risk  Let's take a picture of it, hope you can put it away leem
[music]
Burns Ku ost once per server 2u Cream is delighted Scott
so Deng Pistol Ice Star This time, especially valve a woman the or
will
Peel off the picture, rez Cold Hae Choose
woo woo
[music]
x  There is a tree of words after the talent first, but it
was a part of the fight review update.
[Music]
Ah ah, I had a language fight because they were too
hot.
Split Now, the writing is so good that I forgot it I miss it even when I solve it where
i woo
3 hours is Lalala 5,000 Today I am not bile duct, I don't
shoot the candle and immediately give it 4 lasagna lasagna comes up
after dinner there are palms again from 7 to 11 o'clock  But it went well
Oh, we are rather a song.
Come right away. 7 Chime.
You too came to the viewer and said something.
First Oh, I'm
hungry.  The CSAT is a college entrance exam, so
education means hard work now, but I can do it
sub la la lau de ri sucol poly dian s ang ha
eun turret of honor trembling
n children
September  When I wrote a
joke I laughed at home f La Spray Much to My Day or Fax Monthly
Mutti Children's ng Group's to find the dark old low tide 2 amen heartburn
quickly know now you can go out and say
4 11 o'clock again look at the fortune-telling time  It's because I'm here
before that, and what else do we need more of our members? Oh,
min.
We are mine. This is my nepa-kun.
Yes, this is how I came into the dormitory room.
But Mr. 11:11 was
late. Hobbies are not wasting fans.
As if I went to a self-study room, I have friends who came to study at 14:00 in the morning.
After that, I don’t have any more time.
Try it. If you are curious about more Korean
gangs, can you please come and visit my province with me? If
you have a shorter time in Korea, please
uh co